Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new video for the mandalorian
season three the star wars people just made a
big announcement they also talked about some
of the live-action spin-off series that might
start filming really soon as well too so we'll
break it all down i'm also doing videos for all
the episodes so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all those we'll do a
disney plus membership giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for the mandalorian season
3 on the video so spoiler warning for everything
that's happened on the mandalorian season 2 so far
through episode 2. so starting with number
10 biggest news by far is probably deadline
reporting that boba fett is getting his own
miniseries they didn't say how many episodes
that would be but it gives you a pretty good
idea for what his character arc is going to be
during the mandalorian season too so first big
prediction pretty safe bet that he eventually
reclaims his armor from the mandalorian
by force he's always been something of an
antagonist in the star wars universe the mando
is supposed to be the good honorable character
boba fett has mostly just been portrayed as
the galaxy's most fearsome bounty hunter and
that's about it so number nine either in the
season two finale or sometime around the finale
he moff gideon and the mandalorian will probably
have a classic western three-way mexican standoff
i referenced the good the bad and the ugly during
my mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video because
that's where the classic trope of the three-way
standoff comes from every time you see that gif
of the office with them doing it obviously it's
funny but they're parodying the good the bad and
the ugly movie so in that context mando would be
the good the clint eastwood character maf gideon
would be the bad and boba fett would be the ugly
also really cool clint eastwood easter egg when
they were originally creating the boba fett
character they used clint eastwood's man with
no name character as the main inspiration not only
did it inspire the persona of boba fett in empire
strikes back but also some of his look the classic
western gunslinger but make it science fiction
that's why during season 1 episode 5 the title was
quote unquote the gunslinger it was a reference to
mando who they created based on the boba fett
character he's a gunslinger but it's also a
reference to the original boba fett himself you
can hear the spurs on his boots jingling as he
walks up in that post-credit scene to mingna's
body the same way boba fett's spurs jingle when
he walks like a classic gunslinger the sound of
the spurs was meant to be the huge clue for who
he was supposed to be before they confirmed boba
fett was going to be a big character in season two
number eight boba fett will probably collect
the bounty on baby yoda capturing him for maf
gideon in the finale or by the finale they
mentioned empire strikes back when talking
about the mandalorian season 2 as inspiration and
what happened at the end of empire strikes back
boba fett captured han solo and went to collect
the bounty on it from jabba the hutt it was a
huge downer ending setting the stage for a huge
rescue operation at the beginning of return of the
jedi the next movie so think about how that might
inform the mandalorian season 2 finale boba fett
captures baby yoda and probably gives him to moff
gideon collects the mountain of credits for his
bounty and then takes his armor back from mando
number seven so that they can open the mandalorian
season three episode one with the very return
of the jedi esque rescue operation to save baby
yoda from off gideon also when you think about it
moff gideon wouldn't be a very compelling villain
if he couldn't make good on his threats and he's
already declared that he's taking baby yoda in
that the mandalorian has no idea what he really
is and what he means to the future of the galaxy
so like darth vader chopping off luke's hand in
the empire striking back against the rebellion
for destroying the death star in a new hope moff
gideon has to get some kind of revenge against
the mandalorian for making him take the l so hard
during the season one finale number six boba fett
will also probably get the slave 1 ship back it
would be weird to spend so much time in season
2 episode 1 in episode 2 setting him up getting
his classic armor back reclaiming his identity is
the boba fett you know from the movies to not also
give him back the slave one and if you think about
it between the time he's spent in the sarlacc pit
in the time that he's been out he's been stuck on
tatooine for the past five years based on the end
of episode one it seems like he's been pretending
to be a tuscan raider since he escaped from the
sarlacc pit he's dressed in their robes he has
their traditional weapons on his back so it's just
implied that he's been pretending to be one in the
episode so if he's been with them this whole time
that means that the slave one would be wherever he
left it at the beginning of return of the jedi so
it's really just a matter of him tracking it down
and taking it back from whoever's either stolen
it now or thrown it in another junk pile the same
way the millennium falcon mysteriously wound up
on jakku like he'd been sitting in a scrap yard
for years when they came along even though that
didn't really make a lot of sense like how did the
millennium [ __ ] end up here we don't want to ask
those questions that's like a whole other video
the number five after collecting the bounty
on baby yoda making him rich again boba fett
probably takes his money his ship and his armor
and then heads off into the events of that boba
fett mini-series they didn't really say when
it's going to take place in the timeline it could
always take place in the past but it sounds like
they're setting him up to go off into this special
miniseries deadline's recent report said that that
could start filming as soon as this year but they
didn't say when it would premiere i'm assuming
sometime after the mandalorian season 3 which i
think is going to premiere around this time next
year so the boba fett series would either be at
the end of 2021 or sometime in the first half of
2022 there were some reports earlier this year
that boba fett wouldn't be a huge character on the
mandalorian season 2 but he could become a bigger
character in future seasons that's still possible
but it sounds like most of the attention on his
character would be in this boba fett miniseries
number four the story of the boba fett mini-series
will probably be more of a traditional bounty
hunter saga the way that the mandalorian series
started out now it's kind of turned into more of
a series of fetch quests involving baby yoda and
world building this part of the star wars universe
with a bunch of new characters and lore between
the events of the original trilogy in the new
movies but because they're bringing boba fett
back to redeem him as a character it would also
probably be about him reclaiming the title of
the galaxy's most fearsome bounty hunter remember
the live-action star wars underworld series that
george lucas almost made after revenge of the sith
they filmed a ton of test footage the boba fett
series will probably feel a little bit more like
that was supposed to be they wrote over 50 full
episodes of that all the scripts were ready to go
the reason why they pivoted from that live-action
series though to the animated clone wars series
was mostly because of the budget because of the
technology at the time george lucas wanted to make
it look exactly like the movies like the prequel
movies in order to do that they would have had to
spend about 20 to 25 million dollars per episode
which at the time was just astronomical nowadays
the technology is caught up but they still spend
eight to ten million dollars per an episode of the
mandalorian series so it's still a lot of money
number three the other live-action series they
reported was the live-action ahsoka series
that also implies a similar trajectory for her
character during the mandalorian season two like
she helps the mandalorian and baby yoda on their
quest but then afterwards ahsoka goes off on her
own mission i know everyone wants to see more of
the clone wars in the star wars rebels characters
show up in the live-action series like thrawn ezra
bridger sabine wren those are all characters that
they would probably cover in an ahsoka series
because the last time we saw her she and sabine
were heading into the unknown regions to look for
him and two big prediction everyone's speaking
about ahsoka wondering when we're going to
finally see her during the mandalorian season two
day filoni who created the ahsoka character with
george lucas wrote and directed the mandalorian
season 2 episode 5 so right now if you're laying
bets that would be the episode to bet on she's
being played by rosario dawson who reportedly
signed a contract that would allow her to cameo as
ahsoka on a bunch of other disney plus live action
series in different parts of the timeline i can't
wait to see what kind of digital wizardry they
use to show off some badass ahsoka fight scenes
but ahsoka's in her early 40s during the events of
the mandalorian series so she's still pretty young
at this part of the timeline she never had the
opportunity to meet luke skywalker at least so far
but luke did eventually learn about her in her
history as his father anakin skywalker's padawan
it was just that for the most part she had
been out in the unknown regions during the
events of return of the jedi while luke was
training leia and then later searching for
jedi to create his new academy that's actually
what he's doing right now while all this stuff
in the mandalorian series is happening it's just
that he's in a different part of the galaxy and
right now luke is around his late 20s while this
is all happening so he's still pretty young but
number one biggest prediction about the darksaber
since we still haven't seen a lot of moff gideon
in season two yet obviously we're going to learn
how he took it from bogota and crees which i think
is who he took it from and mando will almost
get his hands on it in present day but the way
giancarlo esposito talks about the darksaber in
the fight scenes that he's been filming with it
mando probably doesn't take it from him yet but
eventually yes i totally think that we'll wind up
with a situation where the mandalorian din jaron
wields the darksaber at least for a little while
then because a lot of the series sounds like it's
the redemption of the mandalorian culture they're
in hiding right now they need to rally he'll
probably pass it on to whoever winds up leading
the mandalorian clans again and eventually all the
mandalorians will formally recognize baby yoda as
a mandalorian himself paying off the theory
that the title of the series the mandalorian
also refers to baby yoda not just din jarrin
but what i'll do is when we get the mandalorian
season 2 finale in december i'll do a new season
3 predictions video just changing things based on
what ends up happening in the rest of the episodes
everyone leave all your predictions in the
comments and there will be more bonus videos this
week but leave all your requests in the comments
as well click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 1 video and click here for my
mandalorian luke skywalker video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!